[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about a major Dragon
Ball super theory that I first outlined
in my what if the grand priest is
actually good video and I will explain
how a brief but potentially very
important scene in episode 120 of Dragon
Ball super might have confirmed that the
story is going in this exact direction
for those of you who haven't seen my
previous video I will give you a quick
summary of the theory and then I will
get into how new information from
episode 120 seems to be pointing in that
same direction if you enjoy the Dragon
Ball super content on this channel leave
a like to let me know if you're new
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and by the way this
coming Saturday we're going to have a
sort of Christmas slash end-of-the-year
twitch discord party on our twitch and
discord so if you want to join us for
that place of party games watch some
Dragon Ball super links are in the
description and we are now posting daily
on our Instagram account so if you use
Instagram feel free to follow us and now
let's get into it many fans have
speculated that because Zeno
and of course future zento behave so
childishly and yet the grand priest
seems so calm calculating and highly
intelligent then the grand priest has to
be evil and manipulating Zeno if you
just search the words grand priest evil
in a youtube search you will find a lot
of videos speculating about how the
grand priest is a villain about how he
is manipulating the Omni King into
erasing the universes but not erasing
the Angels because he wants to free the
Angels at least some of whom if not all
of whom are his children from serving as
assistants or attendants to the gods of
destruction some have even suggested
that the grand priests wife and the
mother of the Angels might have been
erased along with the other six
universes that zenner erased when he got
angry
even before the tournament of power
began and now the grand priest is out
for revenge
or something along those lines however
my theory was that even in the grand
priest is manipulating the childish then
oh he could be doing it for a good cause
he could be doing it to teach sin Oh an
important lesson about life death and
the consequences of his action we stels
Goku and Vegeta that Zeno can destroy
entire universes and even all existence
if he wants to and he also tells them
that there used to be 18 universes all
together but Zeno destroyed six of them
just because he was in a spoiled moon
assuming that we is telling the truth
here then obviously xennos mood greatly
influences his behavior and if he
becomes angry the consequences could be
dire for all of existence what if one
day he gets really mad and decides to
destroy everything this is a very
dangerous situation to be in for
everyone including not just mortals but
also the Angels and the grand priest
himself in episode 77 Dragon Ball super
went out of its way to clearly show us
that the xenos don't know the
consequences of their actions in this
episode Zeno is shown playing a game
where entire planets are being treated
like marbles and essentially the planets
are being hit against each other now the
important thing here is that the Z knows
don't seem to be enjoying the
destruction itself and actually they are
seeing the planets projected as a sort
of hologram this means that they are not
seeing the actual destruction that the
game is causing in the real world which
implies that the xenos are not sadistic
and don't destroy just because they like
to instead Zeno simply thinks that he is
playing a game and he doesn't fully
understand what the consequences of this
game are so it's not that Zeno is evil
but he simply doesn't relate to
portals and they're suffering because he
is so far above them he is in another
realm and yet even though Zeno isn't
evil if he thinks that all of existence
is just a playground for him and he
doesn't understand the consequences of
what he is doing that all of existence
is still in danger of him doing
something rash even though he isn't evil
Zeno could in a fit of anger do
something like erase all of the
universes all of existence again not
because he is a villain but because he's
so innocent that he doesn't understand
what he is actually doing my theory is
that the grand priest is of course
highly intelligent but clearly he cannot
compare empowered to Zeno and because of
xenos childish nature the grand priest
simply cannot explain complex concepts
to him and expect him to understand
right away so after seeing Zeno erase
six universes just because he was in a
spoiled mood the Grand Prix's decided
that the tournament of power would be
the perfect opportunity to teach Sano an
important lesson in the only way that
Xena would understand through a type of
game if you go through the universe
survival arc and watch it carefully you
will notice how many times we see both
xennos having a great time and truly
enjoying the tournament Dragon Ball
super has definitely gone out of its way
again and again to show us that the Omni
King absolutely loves all the fights all
the transformations the cool techniques
and so on but as much fun as Zeno is
having now the tournament is coming to
an end many universes have been erased
already including universe 6 in one of
the most emotional episodes of Dragon
Ball super that really got to me
personally and once the tournament ends
only the winning universe will survive
and the seven others will be erased as
the king of all it is safe to assume
that Zeno lives forever
and after just witnessing a tournament
that he had a great time watching and
enjoyed a great deal at some point he
will realize or the grand priest will
make him realize that he can never
witness
an epic tournament again there will be
only five universes left altogether
including the four that did not need to
compete in the tournament and although
another tournament between those five
remaining universes would be very
interesting it would still feature less
universes less fighters and less
techniques and so on it is important to
remember that having fun is one of xenos
top priority as the being that stands
above all others and as someone who is
usually feared rather than treated with
warmth and friendship he is often bored
and lonely goku noticed this as well
which is why he brought futures and hope
that our current timeline so that Xena
would have someone to play with so if Z
no values playing and having fun above
all else and if the tournament of power
was so much fun for him and way more fun
than anything else we've seen him do in
the entire series then how do you think
he will react at the prospect of never
being able to have fun in this same way
ever again this is where episode 120
comes in in a quick but important scene
we see the Santos looking at the god pad
and they notice how many fighters have
already been eliminated at this point
they say soon it'll be over and they
both look clearly worried and
disappointed for a moment at this exact
moment the grand priest steps in and he
reassures the xenos that now is the time
when the tournament of powers real
thrill begins as the fighters from the
top three universes face off against
each other and while it is true that we
still have a lot of action ahead of us
including the final showdown with Jaden
the fact remains that Zeno lives forever
once the tournament ends he may be
satisfied for a while but to never
witness such a fun tournament again for
all of eternity and to simply go back to
playing marbles with planets seems like
something Xena will not want to do and
this is when the grand priest can step
in once again and tell him that there is
another option if Xena brings back all
the array
University can tell them that in return
for his kindness they will have to
compete in a tournament of power every
few years or so kind of like the
Olympics except instead of countries the
competitors will be all the different
universes Zeno has changed his mind a
body racing universes before like when
he agreed not to erase any universes if
Ferragamo defeats Goku during the Zen
exhibition match and now that Zeno has
seen that mortals have valued that they
are intelligent impressive fighters and
very very entertaining he will be much
less likely to decide to simply erase an
entire universe just because of a bad
mood in the future this is a lesson that
sano never would have learned without
the tournament of power and this really
seems to be the end goal of the Grand
Prix if this does end up being how the
universe survival saga ends it will mean
that Zeno has developed as a character
and also it will mean that many new
possibilities for future arcs have been
created with all these different
universes being brought back they are
now there for us to explore and new
tournaments might be taking place in the
future I also think that it would be
very interesting to have Zeno bring back
all the universes including the six that
he erased before the tournament
I am extremely curious to see what was
happening inside those universes that
they maybe have powerful villains like
Samus ooh and that's why Zeno decided to
erase them just like futures Enel
decided to erase the future timeline and
if so we'll go foo and the others have
to explore these universes and defeat
the villains once the universes are
brought back also we've all noticed that
when a universe is erased
both Zeno and futures and all act to
make it happen together so what if when
Zeno decides to bring back the universes
that were erased and future Seto decides
to act along with him future Zeno
actually brings back the entire future
timeline that he had erased by accident
this would mean that infinite imasu
would return opening yet more
possibilities for epic arcs beyond the
tournament of power at any rate let me
know what you guys think is the
story of Dragon Ball super heading
towards a know being disappointed that
the tournament is over and deciding to
bring back the erased universes so that
he can keep having fun tournaments like
this one in the future are we ever going
to see what is hiding in the six
universes that were being raised before
the tournament and in general what's
next for Dragon Ball super after the
universe survival saga let me know your
thoughts down below if you enjoyed the
Dragon Ball super videos on this channel
be sure to leave a like to let me know
and if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell thank you so much for
your support on this and previous videos
if you want to stay up to date with the
channel be sure to follow us on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar as always
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]